لذا فإن السياق مهم هنا في النرويج مثل
معظم الدول الغربية الأخرى ، فهو
يعطي الأولوية لكبار السن في دور رعاية
المسنين للحصول على اللقاح
أولاً ، لذا سارعت وكالة الأدوية النرويجية
التي هي الجهة المنظمة في هذه الحالة
للإشارة إلى
أن هؤلاء الأشخاص الـ 23 الذين ماتوا بعد
تلقيهم pfizer biontech
كان لقاح covid19 مسنًا وضعيفًا في البداية ،
وقالت الوكالة أيضًا إن
جميع الوفيات التي تحدث في غضون أيام قليلة
بعد التطعيم يتم فحصها
عن كثب ، لذلك تم تقييم 13 من أصل 23 في هذه الحالة
حتى الآن ، وهذا
ما قاله منظم اللقاحات في
بيان
في النرويج ، نحن الآن نقوم بتطعيم
كبار السن والأشخاص في دور رعاية المسنين المصابين
بأمراض كامنة خطيرة ، لذلك من
المتوقع
حدوث وفيات قريبة من وقت
التطعيم
لا يمكننا استبعاد
حدوث ردود فعل سلبية على اللقاح
خلال الأيام الأولى بعد
التطعيم
مثل  حيث أن الحمى والغثيان قد يسهمان
في نتائج أكثر خطورة ونتائج مميتة
لدى المرضى
المصابين  مرض أساسي شديد ، لذا قالت شركة Pfizer
الشركة المصنعة للقاح إنها
تعمل مع مسؤولي الصحة النرويجيين
لجمع
كل المعلومات ذات الصلة ولكنها
أصرّت على
أن عدد الحوادث ليس مقلقًا
وأنه يتماشى مع التوقعات
الآن قد لا تكون هذه الأنواع من الوفيات
فريدة من نوعها  بالنسبة للمسؤولين النرويجيين ، هناك
شفافية تامة عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالإبلاغ العلني عن أي ردود فعل سلبية
على
لقاحات كوفيد ، ولكن على سبيل المثال ، لا يمكن لمنظم اللقاحات في المملكة المتحدة
تحديد عدد
الأشخاص إذا مات أي شخص بعد
تلقيه
لقاح كوفيد في هذا البلد ، لكنه
وعد بهذه البيانات  سيتم
نشرها في وقت ما
سكوت ماكلين سي إن لندن